[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis 20 décembre
bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal de tv 78
tout de suite les titres de l'actualité
locale
les deux départements sont réunis depuis
2007 dans un établissement public
interdépartemental yvelines et
hauts-de-seine ont tenu leur conseil
d'administration hier à jouy en josas
il était question des orientations
budgétaires pour 2010 9,1 objectif
continuer la mutualisation pour faire
des économies
un projet qui fait débat avec l'arrivée
de la ligne 18 à saint quentin en
yvelines en 2030 un nouveau quartier
doit sortir de terre à l'est de
l'agglomération à des modifications de
circulation et des constructions sont
étudiées des réflexions qui suscite
l'inquiétude un collectif d'habitants
mes deux voisins le bretonneux et puis
cette yvelinois va s'envoler pour le cs
de las vegas un facteur de sartrouville
olivier piffeteau fait partie des huit
salariés sélectionnés par la poste pour
présenter sur place les nouveaux
services et innovations du groupe il est
notre invité avec tania saillard délégué
aux relations territoriales des yvelines
pour la poste en plateau également tout
à l'heure catherine marché fondatrice du
cercle d'entrepreneuses bouge ta boîte à
versailles avant de développer ses
titres carlos ghosn peut être bientôt
libérés depuis un mois le patron du
groupe renault implantée notamment et
dans les yvelines à guyancourt et
incarcéré au japon il est accusé de ne
pas avoir déclaré tous ses revenus en
tant que président de nissan en alliance
avec renault et mitsubishi
le tribunal de tokyo vient de rejeter
une demande d'extension de la garde à
vue du pdg le parquet de tokyo a fait
appel de la décision
le conseil d'administration de
l'établissement public
inter-départemental yvelines
hauts-de-seine s'est réuni hier à jouy
en josas à l'ordre du jour les débats à
d'orientation budgétaire 2010 9
créé il ya presque trois ans ces deux
pays a pour but de mutualiser les
services adoption adoption archéologie
pardon préventive ou encore exploitation
du réseau routier les précisions avec ce
sujet d'aurélie rond et nicolas landry
fusionner plusieurs services afin de
réaliser des économies
c'est le principe de l'établissement
inter-départemental yvelines
hauts-de-seine avec un budget qui
devrait tourner autour de 15
le 5 millions d'euros en 2019 les
démarches de rapprochement et de
coopération vont se poursuivre entre les
deux départements
on prend ce qui a lieu dans le
département qui l'a le mieux traités par
exemple nous dans les hauts-de-seine
on a beaucoup gagné au système
d'insertion des yvelines et donc nous
nous avons harmonisé de deux dispositifs
et nous prenons celui des yvelines qui
est meilleur que le nôtre
créée en février 2016 2018 a été la
première année complète de
fonctionnement de cette structure
les orientations budgétaires portaient
notamment sur l'entretien et
l'exploitation du réseau routier des
deux départements
il s'agit du plus gros poste de dépense
pour l'instant nous n'avons réalisé
d'économies que sur le secteur routier
où ce sont plusieurs millions d'euros
qui ont été économisés
c'est un petit établissement public
interdépartemental comparé aux grandes
activités qui sont dans les deux
départements donc c'est au fil du temps
au fil des transferts que ces économies
vont se faire de plus en plus importante
au cours des prochains mois de nouvelles
fonctions seront mutualisés l'éducation
et la commande publique
les présidents des deux départements
s'engageront également dans des projets
des initiatives communes
le vote du budget primitif lui est
prévue le 6 février 2019 et cela fait
partie de la gestion commune entre les
deux départements yvelines et
hauts-de-seine assure la viabilité des
routes pendant l'hiver le plan pour
cette année a été présenté hier à méré
le pays se fixent comme objectif
d'assurer des conditions de circulation
minimal sur mille six cent cinquante
kilomètres de voies jusqu'au 18 mars
pour se faire sans 59 agents sont
mobilisables les agriculteurs aussi
peuvent participer au dispositif en
agissant autour de leurs exploitations
avec leurs tracteurs en 2017-2018 plus
de 800 sorties et une importante action
au moment de l'épisode neigeux de
février des propos recueillis par
nicolas landry
ça nous a permis de regrouper nos moyens
naturellement en hommes et en matériel
et donc de le répartir sur les deux
départements de manière plus
intelligente je dirais l'union fait la
force et on est plus costauds les
hauts-de-seine nous ont apporté surtout
sur la zone urbaine un savoir-faire très
important mais c'est vrai que sur la
période d'hivernage le savoir-faire
yvelinois liée à l'existence d'un réseau
secondaire très important et était aussi
bien utile dans cette union qui fait la
force se fait aussi les économies comme
l'a évoqué patrick et par les temps qui
courent c'est pas une île à trente deux
saleuses et 4000 tonnes de sel sont
prévus pour cette période hivernale dans
les deux départements les yvelines qui
aide les communes carencée en logements
sociaux la loi fixe le seuil minimal à
25% par ville
hier le département a signé une
convention avec le pec qui compte 22,5 %
de logements sociaux une situation loin
d'être inédite sur le territoire
reportage de marie lehn iapichino et de
michael et demi d'euros une enveloppe de
10 7 millions d'euros pour soutenir la
construction de logements sociaux sur la
ville du pecq à commune et le
département signé ce mercredi 19
décembre une convention en ce sens la
ville va pouvoir accueillir une
trentaine de familles supplémentaires
dans un ancien foyer étudiant ça a été
difficile
ce que vous imaginez que c'est quand
même pas simple quand il ya 25 ans prier
terre voilà ça a été assez compliqué
mais c'est quand même incroyable parce
que ce soir on a signé
en un an on a réussi à boucler ce projet
elle avait dubec a donc aujourd'hui tout
24 % de logements sociaux
donc pour nous c'est vraiment formidable
le pecs n'est pas un cas isolé 19 autres
communes du département sont carencés
pour non-respect de leurs objectifs en
termes de logements sociaux
le département voudrait les aider vous
imaginez donc bien que si les communes
n'arrive pas à suivre
ça devient très vite une contrainte
quasi impossible à réduire et ça a des
conséquences très graves pour les
habitants parce qu'il y à des amendes
financières prévues sur le budget de
l'état
tout s'accumule effet que c'est très
défavorable aux libertés communales est
très défavorable à la qualité de vie
dans les communes
selon le département un quart des villes
où elles doivent atteindre l'objectif
des 25 % de logements sociaux dans les
prochaines années
c'est la grand messe du numérique et de
l'innovation le cs computer electronics
show se tient à las vegas du 8 au 12
janvier prochain si facteurs et deux
chargés de la clientèle de la poste
représenteront le groupe sur place parmi
eux un heavy noir olivier picciotto
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes facteur à
sartrouville et vous êtes venu avec
tania saillard bonsoir un moment ça vous
êtes délégué aux relations territoriales
des yvelines pour le groupe la poste
première question qui s'adresse à vous
pourquoi envoyer des postiers à las
vegas ça nous paraît évident que ce soit
les facteurs et les postiers qui
connaissent le groupe et qui proposent
nos produits et nos services
quotidiennement qui nous représente
directement lors de cet événement c'est
la cinquième année que la poste sera
présente sur le cs de las vegas pourquoi
il faut y être associés aux us c'est le
moment l'événement du numérique
le groupe est dans un réel projet de
digitalisation et de démocratisation du
numérique qui nous paraît là encore
essentiel d'être présent sur cet
événement et vous êtes donc délégué aux
relations territoriales sur les yvelines
c'est une fierté que le territoire des
lignes soit soit représenté pour suez
bien sûr on est ravis qu olivier soient
présents qu'ils puissent parrainer des
yvelines et qui les y qui il est
vocation à aller sur cet événement c'est
bien pompiers grandiose justement
olivier piveteau comment vous avez
accueilli la nouvelle de partir pour ce
csd très très bonne surprise
voilà il y avait il ya eu pas mal de
travail à pour la sélection donc donc
content que ça porte ses fruits déjà
pour commencer et puis d'avoir cette
opportunité il ya parlé de sélection
comment ça s'est effectuée justement la
sélection alors on a reçu les consignes
à peu près un mois avant il s'agissait
de réaliser une vidéo dans laquelle on
présentait un produit imaginaire de la
poste et en essayant de deux dents
parler le mieux possible de mettre en
avant
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qui contiendrait comme innovation qu'est
ce qui sera intéressant
en l'occurrence là l'idée ce serait un
colis digital on enverra un fichier 3d
un bureau de poste qu'il imprime pour
nous et l'envoie au destinataire qui à
la porte d'à côté donc un gain de temps
c'est plus vert parce que moins de moins
de transport etc plus c'est plus
sécurisant pour l'objet qui n'est pas
transvaser autant que un objet qu'ils
feraient tout le tout le trajet donc ça
c'est un produit qui n'existe pas mais
sur lequel on a du voile à faire une
vidéo pour pour en présenter les
avantages ont été sélectionnés sur
balles
si notre vidéo était convaincante et si
elles étaient vos motivations pourquoi
candidater finalement alors c'est une
opportunité assez assez inattendu en
tant que facteur d'aller représenter le
groupe
un salon comme celui ci moi ma
motivation c'était pas d'assister aux
crs il y aura beaucoup de très très
grande boîte mondial aura google dû
rater cela
donc donc par curiosité pour pourvoir
tous qui tout ce qui est amenée à
exister dans les jours à venir fin dans
le futur c'est quelque chose de très
intéressant et mac est sûre ça vous de
pardon le métier de facteur aujourd'hui
a évolué il ya une grande part du
numérique maintenant dans ce métier de
facteur énorme ça c'est un petit produit
que je les ai emmenés qu'il sera au c
est ce qu on appelle le diable c'est
pour nous le porte-monnaie de demain
c'est le futur porte monnaie des enfants
il est
il fonctionne sur les tpe sans contact
il a la tête d'un téléphone avec les
petits produits que les enfants adorent
y est associée ça marche très très bien
il a en pré réservation est déjà un
certain nombre de personnes l'utilisent
en test il est aussi proposé pour les
personnes qui sont sous tutelle de
justice ou pour les personnes âgées qui
auraient des difficultés à avoir de la
monnaie dans leur poche va donner de la
monnaie à leurs aides ménagères et on se
rend bien compte que ça c'est une vraie
démocratisation du numérique
ça je le pose sur le tp sans contact et
j'ai acheté ma baguette il ya le
numérique prend une part de plus en plus
importante je vous interromps culture
l'émission ocvs elles vont qu'elles vont
être ses émissions alors il s'agira
essentiellement de présenter les
différentes innovations de la poste des
innovations qui font parfois partie du
quotidien des postiers quand il s'agit
voilà deux de mes médicaments chez moi
ou un facteur peut amener les
médicaments d'une personne isolée chez
elles ou bien de l'offre veiller sur mes
parents voilà en règle générale la poste
se numériser puis la pote accompagne les
citoyens en règle générale dans la
numérisation de la société faciliter
notamment les démarches en ligne
enfin tout ce tout ce genre de choses et
il y aura forcément des présentations en
anglais sur place et ce que l'anglais
vous le maîtriser alors j'ai la chance
de me débrouiller oui je dois bien en
anglais voilà en tout cas pour pour mes
collègues qui m'accompagnent on a une
formation pour être capable de peach et
en anglais et tout le monde tout le
monde s'attend à être être capable au
moins deux pro présenter les produits de
la patrie et c'est forcément un voyage
qui se prépare et vous avez suivi une
formation c'est ça c était proposé aux
personnes qui vont partir à las vegas la
formation pour les personnes qui vont
partir et obligatoire pour s'assurer que
l'on sera bien en mesure de tenir notre
rôle là bas de connaître les produits
dont on va parler de d'être capable de
les présenter en anglais aussi
voilà et c'est une formation sur les
produits et sur le pitch on va dire sur
l'anglais et on vous souhaite bon voyage
merci olivier piveteau d'avoir été avec
tout postier à sartrouville il faisait
donc participer aux crs de las vegas
merci également à à tania sayara délégué
aux relations territoriales des yvelines
pour le groupe la poste merci d'avoir
été avec nous en plateau un sujet plus
local
à présent le futur quartier de la ligne
à 18 50 1 est et étudié en ce moment il
prévoit des modifications de circulation
également la construction de logements
en vue de l'arrivée du métro en 2030 sur
l'ancien site de thalès un projet qui
inquiète un collectif d'habitants de
voisins-le-bretonneux car tout proche du
quartier de la bretonnière les
précisions de manon varalda un projet
qui fait débat dans le cadre de
l'aménagement du futur quartier la gare
de la ligne 18 50 ans est un dévoiement
de l'ère des 91 est prévu cette
départementale fait la jonction entre
versailles et la vallée de chevreuse en
traversant guyancourt et voisins le
bretonneux
cette déviation s'effectuera en deux
fois deux voies en prolongement de
l'avenue de l'europe la route arriverait
alors depuis guyancourt et le
technocentre renault directement sur le
quartier de la bretonnière de
voisins-le-bretonneux les membres de
l'adav association de défense des
habitants de la ville vit chinoises
redoutent les conséquences de ce projet
on imagine flux de circulation qui sera
très important avec un tourne à gauche à
hauteur du campanile alors
qu'aujourd'hui
cette acres de la d81 venant de
versailles la minière et à lanvallay
vers la vallée de chevreuse traverse
directement le carrefour ces
modifications de circulation
s'accompagne de la construction de 1300
logements d'ici 2030 sur l'ancien site
de l'entreprise thalès plus un parking
de 800 places un parking relais pour les
gens qui fréquenteront la ligne de métro
imaginé qui a à peu près de 4000
personnes soit un tiers de la population
de voisins qui vont évoluer dans ce
quartier où convergeait vers ce quartier
donc un tiers de la population de
voisins sur un terrain qui fait 20
hectares un dixième de la surface de
voisins-le-bretonneux on imagine des
conséquences que ça aura l'adav défend
le contournement sud de
voisins-le-bretonneux qui était prévu à
l'origine de la ville nouvelle
contacté par notre rédaction la mère de
voisins-le-bretonneux alexandra rosetti
n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer sur le sujet
et avant d'accueillir ma deuxième invité
marylène yapi shiloh est également avec
mon plateau mont soir en salle la
rédaction de tv 78 alors 2019 sera une
année électorale le dimanche 26 mai nous
voterons pour les européennes plus de
scrutin régional on passe à huit
circonscriptions huit circonscriptions à
une seule au niveau national mais pour
pouvoir voter
marianne il faut être bien sûr inscrits
sur les listes électorales effectivement
grégory si vous n'êtes pas inscrit sur
les listes de votre commune vous avez
trois solutions possibles l'inscription
en mairie par vaux où un tiers avec une
procuration écrite sur internet sur le
site du service public
vérifiez avant que ce moyen est possible
dans votre ville le service et des
poètes est disponible pour huit communes
à saint quentin en yvelines
enfin par courrier à l'adresse de votre
mairie nouveauté cette année pas besoin
de se précipiter avant le 31 décembre
vous avez jusqu'au 31 mars 2019 pour
vous inscrire mais attention ne pas trop
traîné pour autant le plus vite et le
mieux pour nous et sinon la date
officielle si le 31 mars mais comme le
31 mars et 1 dimanche en fait ce sera le
samedi 30 mars
donc il est évident qu'il faut éviter de
venir
et surtout pas d'envoyer le courrier le
30 mars puisque c'est la date de
réception en mairie qui compte et non
pas la date d'envoi
évidemment il faut des documents
spécifiques
une pièce d'identité valide ou périmés
mais depuis moins de cinq ans une
facture justifiant son domicile et le
document cerfa de demandes d'inscription
complété et qui peut s'inscrire
alors il faut s'inscrire si on a changé
de domicile pour pouvoir voter au bureau
le plus proche de chez soi même si vous
avez déménagé au sein de la même commune
les jeunes qui auront atteint leur 18
ans jusqu'à la veille des élections sont
inscrits aux tomates automatiquement
s'ils ont bien accompli leurs formalités
de recensement à 16 ans enfin les
citoyens européens peuvent s'inscrire
sur les listes complémentaires pour ces
élections
merci marylène et n'oubliez pas les
missions le 7-8 europe de nicolas
kirillovitch chaque mois sur tv à 78
pour en savoir plus sur ces élections
européennes une page économique avec une
nouvelle invitée je disais tout à
l'heure en plateau catherine marché
bonsoir ça vous êtes dirigeante et
fondatrice de pythagore une société
spécialisée dans les solutions en
ressources humaines et vous êtes venu
nous parler ce soit du réseau vous avez
fondé à versailles le cercle bouge ta
boîte à l'origine c'est un réseau qui a
été créée en bretagne en 2016 pour
assembler des chats des femmes pardon
est chef d'entreprise
pourquoi vous avez décidé de développer
ce réseau à versailles alors tout
d'abord c'est effectivement le premier
réseau business pour femme chef
d'entreprise dans les yvelines
et pour moi il ça manquait effectivement
bouge ta boîte m'a séduite
notamment lorsque j'ai pu rencontrer sa
fondatrice marie et loi notamment par
ses valeurs des valeurs d'entr'aide
partage de bienveillance qui sont aussi
les miennes et quels sont les objectifs
de ce collectif de ce
ce réseau pardon alors les objectifs
c'est s'entraider en faisant du business
ensemble également partagé pourquoi pas
des thématiques telles que hergé le
pitch enfin des thématiques de chefs
d'entreprise et partager de
l'information pour pouvoir faire
propulser notre business alors on l'a
dit au niveau national c'est écrit en
bretagne en 2016 comment on lance un ce
type de réseau à versailles comment vous
y êtes prise alors au départ mari est
venu nous présenter le concept et
plusieurs chefs d'entreprise avaient été
conviés et ensuite je me suis dit
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas prendre le
lead sur ce réseau et autour de moi j'ai
réuni d'autres jeunes femmes qui avaient
des activités différentes puisque le but
est aussi d'avoir des métiers
complémentaires ou des métiers
complètement différent pour pouvoir se
recommander pour pouvoir sa portée ou
également dans la richesse et la
diversité et d'avoir des parcours autour
de la table qui nous permettent aussi
d'avoir un maillage local et régional
puissant on a compris les valeurs qu'est
ce qu'on y fait concrètement qu'est ce
que vous y faites concrètement dans ce
groupe alors comme tout réseau vont se
recommandent on se présente on sauve
représente ce qu'on appelle le pitch une
minute ensuite l'une d'entre nous va
également présenter son métier pendant
dix minutes à ses consoeurs et enfin
notre valeur ajoutée en tant que que
cercle de femmes chefs d'entreprise au
delà notre recommandation c'est de sa
portée avec soit des ateliers qu'on
appelle le créatif c'est à dire comme je
vous disais on va avoir une thématique
est l'une d'entre nous va se saisir de
cette thématique pour apporter à l'autre
ou alors on va avoir un invité inspirant
qui va nous parcours nous donner son
parcours ou bien également va faire
marcher l'intelligence collective
chacune d'entre nous peut être confronté
à des problématiques de développement de
sociétés ou de présentations etc et les
autres par son apport et ces
propositions vont pouvoir amener une
solution à laquelle n'avait pas pensé et
donc la faire grandir et lui proposer
une vraie solution est donc cette valeur
ajoutée et qu'est ce que c'est
aujourd'hui
femmes chefs d'entreprise alors être
femme chef d'entreprise aujourd'hui
c'est un vrai défi avant de chalenge on
sait que 38% des femmes créent les
entreprises et aussi ce pourquoi marie a
fondé ce club c'est tout simplement 12%
seulement vivre de cette activité
donc derrière c'est beaucoup d'énergie
pour développer développer sa boîte et
donc cette énergie elle vient tout
simplement parce que nous les femmes on
a plusieurs vies nous en 24 heures une
vie pro une vie perso et on ne prend pas
forcément le temps de développer un
réseau
moi même je suis une ancienne une
ancienne drh et 20 ans d'expérience dans
cette fonction
avant de créer ma société et c'est vrai
que je n'ai pas pris ce temps de
développer un réseau et c'est ce à quoi
nous pêchons et c'est ce pourquoi ce
club existe et au travers des échanges
que vous avez pu avoir au sein de ce
club c'est les difficultés qui
ressortent tout à fait là la difficulté
d'avoir un réseau finalement la
difficulté d'avoir un réseau aussi le
fait de ne plus être celle de dettes
aussi de partager un quotidien de
partager les doutes et partager des
joies et des réussites donc donc c'est
vrai que c'est un réseau extrêmement
dynamique est également un réseau
aujourd'hui qui cherchent des
entreprises marraine dans 700 vaincra je
dirais locale quand je dis marraine on
ne demande pas d'argent
1 c'est tout simplement que des
entreprises des pme des start up des
grandes entreprises viennent nous
soutenir
on a effectivement des partenaires très
affichée tels que bnp paribas qui nous
ouvre ses portes tous les quinze jours
on a également axa qui nous épaule et la
bpi qui nous a permis de lancer ce
concept est aujourd'hui je me dis
pourquoi pas en local on
desmarest nationale mais pourquoi pas en
local qui nous permettrait de se
connaître
2 pourquoi pas travailler ensemble
d'avoir un espace où on peut échanger ou
on peut aussi amener notre expérience
auprès des collaborateurs si
l'entreprise et travaille sur la rse et
l'entrepreneuriat donc voilà c'est des
échanges comme ça tout simplement que
j'aimerais également tissé dans le
maillage économique qui pourrait
rapidement comme on adhère à bouge ta
boite on adhère en allant sur le site
déjà en venant nous voir en participant
à une réunion en allant sur le site et
en cliquant sur nous rejoindre merci
catherine marché d'être venu sur ce
plateau je rappelle vous est la
fondatrice du réseau bouge ta boîte à
versailles également dirigeante de la
société
pythagore merci cette année les
signalements d'agressions homophobes ont
augmenté de 15% l'association urgence
homophobie lance une campagne pour
dénoncer ces violences en attaque pour
témoigner leur histoire mon histoire et
un clip musical de l'amour auquel a
participé 70 personnalités parmi elles
un rambolitains le chanteur tim dup la
rencontre la vidéo raconta l'histoire
dasa matt réfugiés accueillis par
l'association est victime de violence
homophobe
suite et fin à présent de notre dossier
de la rédaction sur les idées de cadeaux
locales et si vous n'avez pas terminé
vos achats de noël c'est également
possible d'offrir un cadeau fait main le
do it yourself est à la mode en ce
moment maintenant varaldo s'est rendu à
deux ateliers organisés pour les seniors
aux clayes-sous-bois à l'espace
jacqueline auriol des clayes-sous-bois
les petites mains s'affairent pour
confectionner un cadeau et pas n'importe
lequel puisqu'il est fait main les
participantes s'attaque à une
composition florale de quoi égayer ses
tables de fêtes de zama reggae
des des boules de ou du gypsophile du
branchage de noël des bâtons de cannelle
des boules des rondelles d'orange et de
pommes
j'adore sa voix j'adore tout ce qui est
loisirs créatifs
cet atelier était dirigée par une
fleuriste de villepreux qui veille à
prendre des fleurs de saison ce sont des
compositions de noël faites à base
d'amaryllis une fleur de saison une
fleurs à bulbes donc là ce sont des
amaryllis couper que l'on pique dans de
la mousse et après que l'on agrémentent
avec des plaintes décorations de noël du
sapin des petites boules
des des fleurs fraîches également battu
les yankees son ami
et on a mis également après plein de
petits sujets le fait main est loin
d'être dépassé un autre atelier cartes
de voeux en scrapbooking étaient
proposées la grande banque va être comme
ça
la toute petite de 2 cm de large
elle va être ici et là cette partie là
le bout on va le coller sur la bande
le matériel était mis à disposition
ainsi que le savoir faire de chacune
une fois qu'on a le matériel c'est
d'abord d'avoir un papier de fond style
papier canson un papier de déco et puis
d embellissement
après les étapes techniques place à la
décoration papier ruban stickers les
créatrices avait tout cela disposition
pour laisser cours à leur imagination
c'est du plaisir
safran et puis ça passe le temps et puis
et puis voir pu voir comment on fait ça
s'écarte créer sa propre car de ses
mains permet un cadeau personnalisé
il ya plaisir de faire allier le plaisir
d'offrir parce que je sais que les gens
auxquels j'offre des gens voient des cas
les gardent donc ça déjà ça m'a fait
plaisir
comptez entre une à trois heures pour
concevoir sa carton scrapbooking enfin
terminée les participantes étaient ravis
je suis fier tout simplement c'est des
ateliers met en évidence une des valeurs
de noël le partage avec ses proches et
puis avant de refermer ce journal une
petite touche de sourire à quelques
jours de noël nous sommes allés demander
aux yvelinois mais pas que quelles
étaient leurs chants de noël préféré
c'est au micro de michael et demi
d'euros et de patrick jacques de dixmude
[Applaudissements]
côtier descendra du ciel
bon tu as bien se couvrir ses forces à
bien ce petit papa noël quand tu
descendras du ciel avec eux des souliers
par milliers
or seront
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
valet
ça
highlight all in
et au lit ce cas
volley
les slaves et de feliz navidad ça ne
manquez pas ce soir la venue du père
noël il nous fait l'honneur de passer
par nos studios avant sa grande tournée
mondiale il est l'invité de marylène
iapichino dans le 7-8 loisirs après ce
journal est d'ailleurs toute l'équipe 2
tv 60,18 vous propose une émission
spéciale fêtes de fin d'année à
retrouver notamment ce lundi à 24
décembre à 21h en attendant le père noël
à de nombreux invités reportages et
surprise c'est la fin du set 8 journal
qui prend à ses quartiers d'hiver retour
à l'antenne après quelques repas copieux
le mercredi 2 janvier 2019 d'ici là à
passer de très bonnes fêtes de fin
d'année belle soirée à tous avec tv 78
[Musique]